[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette autre
édition d' espace autochtone en direct
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse à la
dramaturgie wii et à la littérature
autochtone avec une invitée qui n'est
pas encore tout à fait arriver mais
allez en route donc nous allons
l'accueillir dans quelques instants mais
je vous présente tout de suite nos
chroniqueuse cette semaine mme isabelle
picard et à québec dans les studios de
radio canada à québec bonjour isabelle
bonjour ça va bien oui ça va très bien
merci
oui très bien alors naqab bertrand qui
est notre invité devrait arriver dans
quelques instants isabelle je vous
présente également maty sarr et qui est
là en remplacement d'elie ch et dit
chacun sur l'article exactement alors
bonjour à toutes les deux en fait on va
parler aujourd'hui de dramaturgie on va
parler de littérature autochtones parce
qu'il ya deux événements qui se
déroulent actuellement à montréal il ya
le festival du jamais lu qui met en
vedette des dramaturges connus ou moins
connus ou pas connus du tout et puis il
ya metropolis bleu et là on s'intéresse
beaucoup plus à la littérature
alors première question à isabelle est
ce que vous connaissez ces deux
festivals est ce que vous avez déjà
fréquenté non malheureusement je
connaissais quand même le metropolis
bleu de réputation mais non je n'ai
jamais plus
il ya lyne aidans unis dans l'autre
d'accord donc ça va être une découverte
parce que la place est faite cette année
pour les autochtones les autochtones
sont présents dans l'un comme dans
l'autre en assez grand nombre c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'on reçoit naka bertrand
parce que elle est autochtone et on l'a
évité avec le jamais lu comme
codirectrice artistique donc elle a
choisi d des dramaturges autochtones qui
vont faire partie de cet événement jeudi
qu'ils vont mais en réalité c'est
commencé depuis le 2 mai donc depuis
hier
mathis vous les connaissez les festivals
non c'est aussi une découverte un peu
pour moi et puis on verra un peu en
fonction de ce que ce que notre invité
est devenu vont nous dire à propos du
festival moi j'ai je me suis tourné
davantage vers les territoires du
nord-ouest me suis interrogé sur ce que
l'on était en matière de théâtre et
psychiquement et dramaturgie donc ce
serait intéressant de pouvoir comparer
ce qui se fait de voir si éventuellement
aussi dans les prochaines années si
peut-être d
des artistes et des dramaturges qu'on va
pouvoir suivre à travers justement le
jeune festival django est absolument
parce que l'intérêt c'est qu'on va
parler de dramaturgie contemporaine
par contre avec vous les abel on va
parler de dramaturgie et de littérature
surtout futuriste on rentre dans un
monde qui nous est encore inconnue en
réalité oui oui c'est un courant au fait
qui est relativement nouveau au québec
oui là on parle de futurisme autochtone
ou 2 oct au futurisme
c'est en fait je veux prendre le temps
de bien bien vous l'expliquer parce que
c'est il ya plusieurs facettes à tout ça
en fait c'est un mouvement artistique et
culturel qui permet par des perspectives
autochtone présentes et passées de se
projeter dans le futur dans l'avenir et
ça on le fait beaucoup en science
fiction et on le fait dans tous les
domaines artistiques donc autant au
niveau de la danse du théâtre de la
littérature des balades ou même donc de
tout ce qui est virtuel également de la
musique et de la bande dessinée
donc c'est vraiment le top two futuriste
c'est se projeter vers le futur être
capable de rêver de s'imaginer un futur
en s'appuyant sur la tradition sur la
culture bien sûr sur la spiritualité
mais un peu de se réinventer à travers
tout ça comme comme autochtones comme
membre des premiers peuples
donc c'est c'est très nouveau c'est
surtout très positif pour un peuple
d'être capable de se projeter vers
l'avenir on le sait les premières
nations les premiers peuples
c'est souvent une représentation qui est
passéiste qui est basé sur le passé sur
le avant l'arrivée des colons ou même au
moment du contact ou les effets les
pensionnats che terrain et on est
cependant régler un peu dépensé des
blessures du passé
la réconciliation même si on est
contemporaine on est encore dans le
passé et là c'est carrément on se
projette vers vers l'avenir
on a pu non plus dans cet art l'appui
qui projette les premières nations vers
l'avenir une vision qui était pour
longtemps
pendant longtemps dans le milieu des
arts qui était eurocentriste je me
souviens d'avoir vu des peintures de
théophile hamel ou des sculptures de
tâches et où les autochtones représentés
étaient toujours un peu les mêmes
c'est l'image de l'autochtone avec la
coiffe l'autochtone sur le cheval un peu
sauvage où la femme autochtone un peu
soumises assez sexy aussi donc on était
toujours dans une image qui était dans
le passé et même on aurait dû qu'à une
certaine époque était autochtone
seulement cela qui se représentait de
cette manière alors qu'on est on est
contemporain on est aussi capable de
s'imaginer dans le futur alors le tokyo
futuriste c'est sortir de ce paradigme
finalement qui qui nous projetait qui
nous qui nous tourner vers le passé et
c'est une fusée on se passer dit qu'ils
nous confient n'y a qu'à les voir et on
utilise aussi beaucoup des technologies
contemporaines pour se réinventer ça je
pense que c'est un outil qui fait en
sorte que ce courant l'a peut être très
fort notamment au canada anglais donc on
est plus juste en réaction dans le
top-ten futurisme ont construit notre
futur va se l'imaginer à la hauteur de
ce qu'on veut être on se réapproprie
notre identité et on en profite par le
fait même pour corriger des erreurs du
passé pourquoi pas oui on peut le faire
on est dedans on est dans l'imaginaire
d'où il vient ce courant fait au comment
il est né ben en fait c'est un phénomène
qui n'est pas nouveau si on regarde
certaines prophéties du passé notamment
la prophétie des sept feux prophétie
anishnabe donc objet audition oui c'est
ça exactement you des centaines d'années
déjà cette profession a vu le jour et on
imaginait à ce moment à travers une
vision futuriste du monde
on imaginait les sociétés autochtones
dans cette génération ou à peu près donc
on imaginait des grandes périodes de
l'histoire on imaginer des changements
et là on est arrivé au 7e feu ou à peu
près selon la prophétie et c'est le
temps encore une fois maintenant de se
réinventer comme premières nations comme
premiers peuples et comme disait louis
riel ce sont les artistes qui rendront à
mon peuple
l'heure et je trouve ça vraiment très
beau c'est souvent par l'art qu'on est
capable effectivement de se réinventer
l'art c'est une porte un finalement
sur notre société c'est une porte sur le
futur et donc c'est un courant qui vient
des états unis qui est très fort aussi
au canada anglais mais qui fait son
chemin quand même jusqu'à nous au québec
maintenant je sais qu'en littérature
notamment il ya deux projets sur la
table au niveau du futurisme autochtones
oui j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a un
c'est votre projet parce que c'est ça
vous êtes en écriture est actuellement
sur ce produit
je suis en écriture ben en fait le pour
l'instant je complète un roman jeunesse
donc je peux en parler puisque c'est
signé mais c'est de la littérature
jeunesse c'est très contemporain et je
pense que c'est un roman qui va
s'adresser aux 12 à 16 ans environ et
qui va faire connaître le monde
autochtone contemporain maintenant en
réfléchissant sur le concept de
futurisme autochtone et déjà quelqu'un
moi j'ai en tête un roman adulte qui va
parce que vous savez au niveau du
futurisme autochtone on n'est pas obligé
de deux de se pousser à 500 ans d'ici là
on peut regarder déjà vers l'avenir dans
vingt ans dans 30 ans alors le roman que
je vais commencer cet été
ça va être une histoire qui va se
projeter dans 20 30 ans de six ans comme
un but on n'a pas besoin d'aller au delà
de ça déjà 20 ans et un futur proche
mais intéressé oui absolument on est
dans le futur et les choses vont
probablement avoir changé de sujet étant
alors pourquoi de cette façon là oui
alors on pourrait regarder on attend
toujours notre invité nakai devrait
arriver sous peu donc ça va nous
permettre de voir des exemples là qui
existe déjà mais dans dans divers
domaines de l'art autochtone parce que
c'est pas juste en littérature donc non
c'est ce que c'est pas seulement la
littérature au niveau de la bd you la bd
torontoise moonshot c'est une série de
bandes dessinées en fait qu'ils sont en
anglais mais dont + qui sont faites par
des membres des premières nations hôtes
en l'illustration que l'histoire et
certaines de ces histoires sont
résolument tournées vers le futur donc
on fait on se projette évidemment
certains auteurs love ont utilisé la
science fiction pour projeter les
sociétés autochtones dans un futur assez
plus ou moins lointain en fait ici une
centaine
années quand même et donc ça ça peut
être intéressant il ya aussi marjo qui
l'année passée au mis en place en tout
cas il ya trouvé une nouvelle héroïne
inouk qui s'appelle snowboard
oui donc soucier c'est la science
fiction on est donc ça c'est à suivre
également au niveau des balados de plus
en plus à la mode les fameux podcast il
y en a un qui s'appelle métis in space
mais tu es in space et les deux
animatrices molly sweeney chelsea va one
il parle en fait ce qu'elles font c'est
qu'elle écoute des fictions que ce soit
des téléséries ou encore des films où
les autochtones sont à l'honneur dans le
futur donc ce sont des sciences fiction
et elles vont commenter un peu tout ça
et ce sont des défections qui
proviennent de partout dans le monde
j'ai écouté dernièrement s est une
fiction qui provenaient de la nouvelle
zélande et qui mettait en scène des
maoris dans deux décennies environ
donc ça ça peut être intéressant
également regarder donc ça nous fait
connaître par se baladent aulas on peut
connaître toutes sortes de films de
télésérie qui met en scène des premières
nations dans un futur plus ou moins
rapproché mettre maintenant au niveau de
la littérature ya quand même une
incontournable ses chéris du mali qui
est une métisse de réduire au manitoba
et qui fait dans la littérature jeunesse
aussi elle en est à son cinquième roman
déjà un roman qui vient d'être traduit
en français et qui se nomme pilleurs de
rêve et qui est publié chez boréal donc
un roman qui a gagné plusieurs prix
c'est un grand succès au canada anglais
et le roman nous transporte en fait dans
une époque apocalyptique où post
apocalyptique où seuls les autochtones
ont encore le pouvoir de rêver c'est une
question de génétique parait-il dans le
roman et c'est une histoire qui est
plutôt semble qui va se construire
autour de ce pouvoir de rêver
l'envy finalement que les autres ont de
pouvoir encore rêver mais c'est
seulement les autochtones qui l'ont
alors les autochtones vont être un peu
et pied ils vont être traqués et toute
l'histoire se bâtit à travers ça donc
c'est quand même oui oui absolument
il ya du futurisme aussi en musique
autochtone
oui oui ben en fait c'est que on mélange
des sons très avant gardiste très très
contemporain avec des sons du passé et
ça ça nous pose quelque part dans un
courant qui est plutôt futuriste et là
je parle notamment de jeremy nature qui
utilisent des tambours mélangé avec un
univers autochtone même avec de
l'électro parfois la musique
électronique et c'est la même chose pour
traille corde raide donc un groupe
d'ottawa qui va mélanger le tambour avec
des sons électro qui veut donner quelque
chose d'assez un genre assez nouveau
totalement intéressant pour la musique
des premières nations et d'ailleurs je
pense que ça se fait aussi chez les
inuit je les ai entendues avec certains
groupes inuits ou ont mélangé les chants
de gorge l'échangeur son coup le centre
oui absolument mais qui sont
complètement réinterpréter puis en même
temps où il ya de la musique
contemporaine qui vient se mêler à ça et
qui amène à sont complètement nouveau
complètement avant gardiste en fait mais
les champs gorge même on parle de
musique mais même dans le pays il ya
tellement disciplines artistiques qui
sont qui viennent se compléter les zones
d autres en fait c'est difficile de s je
pense de scinder aussi c'est les
disciplines oui oui on la musique va se
retrouver dans le théâtre et puis
à la bhl les contes traditionnels vont
se retranscrit dans la littérature mais
aussi dans le théâtre est aussi dans les
chants de gorge parce qu'on est dans la
passation de tradition de savoir et de
comptines wilko oui oui oui dans les
chants de gorge aussi donc je pense que
c'est aussi beaucoup le mariage des
performances artistiques
oui la parlons-en du théâtre il avait
parce que justement le théâtre aussi
s'intéresse au futurisme autochtone oui
en fait il ya quelques compagnies de
théâtre qui vont utiliser évidemment qui
vont qui vont projeter les autochtones
dans l'avenir même si au québec
honnêtement j'ai fait des recherches et
on est beaucoup dans le passé on est
encore beaucoup dans la réconciliation
dans la sensibilisation peut-être
l'éducation si à travers le théâtre de
ckoi être autochtone aujourd'hui
maintenant il ya quand même les
productions aux niches cas qu'ils ont
faits qui font toutes sortes de choses
et qui entre autres font des courts
métrages et il y en a un qui s'appelle
riz compose donc c'est un court métrage
qui a été fait par des très jeunes
autochtones on parle de 25 ans et moins
et donc évidemment les autochtones à
travers le film on parle déjà de 2015 si
je me trompe pas se tourner vers
l'avenir donc c'est quoi l'avenir
autochtone comment ils perçoivent leur
vie d'adulte finalement sur le
territoire canadien dans les prochaines
années
donc mais c'est vraiment on en est aux
balbutiements au québec mais c'est
extrêmement positif de voir qu'il ya
quand même des projets qui émergent et
qu'on n'est pas seulement justement
tourné vers le passé mais qu'on
s'imagine le futur et donc ça veut dire
à quelque part qu'on aura un futur le
message finalement sous jacent oui et
justement est-ce que c'est un futur qui
est positif est ce que c'est un futur
qui donne envie de s'y rendre
dans ce que j'ai vu absolument dingue
j'ai entendu absolument oui c'est un
futur où les autochtones sont souvent en
position de sauveur quand même on parle
des changements climatiques bon tout ce
qu'ils les impacts environnementaux les
autochtones
on veut pas se le cacher ils sont très
près encore du territoire qui ont des
connaissances
millénaire finalement par rapport à tout
ça et les histoires tournent autour de
souvent du post apocalyptique comme les
autochtones vont prendre une place
beaucoup plus importante dans les
sociétés étant donné notamment c'est
savoir le et d'ailleurs vous dans votre
roman bon je sais que vous me raconterez
pas l'histoire mais est-ce qu'il est
positif aussi est ce que c'est ce qui se
passe dans 20 ans va réjouir les
autochtones et les non autochtones qui
vont le lire
oui oui je pense que oui ce c2c d'aller
là où on n'est pas capable d'aller
finalement maintenant parce que on est
lié par la loi sur les indiens on est on
est on est encadré par toutes sortes de
loi de programme de frontières qui font
en sorte on n'est pas capable de
pleinement être qui nous voulons être et
donc le roman la littérature et les arts
finalement nous permettre d'aller au
delà de ça donc je pense que oui il faut
que ça soit positif
oui louis-riel l'avait dit à il ne
s'était pas trompé oui alors elle ne
bougeait pas parce qu'on va s'intéresser
au théâtre dans l'arctique on va voir
s'il ya un volet futuriste dans le
théâtre en arctique on pourrait
commencer par ce qui se passe d'abord au
nunavut parce qu'on va regarder deux
régions nunavut nunavik et toutes sortes
d'initiatives en fait qu'ils sont nés au
cours des dernières années et qui
permettent aux inuit de s'exprimer par
le t1 oui alors avant d'en venir au
futurisme autochtone il faut se demander
aussi commun d'où viennent ce qui si l
information s'il ya des endroits pour
les blancs food & drug dans food
exactement on voit beaucoup dans le sud
du pays des initiatives qui visent à
former les jeunes autochtones ou à la
mise en scène au jeu théâtral et cetera
donc au québec on l'a vu aussi à
montréal avec le programme de résidence
autochtone de l'école nationale de
théâtre du canada où auparavant aussi la
compagnie théâtrale ondine occupait au
frais une formation qui était
exclusivement destinée à des
des autochtones il ya le centre pour la
perte autochtone qui est à toronto en
ontario en alberta aussi à edmonton ya
autochtone alberta qui étonne
l'organisme un cocktail de théâtre et de
danse de la scène donc des initiatives
beaucoup dans le sud du pays mais dans
le nord si on ceci on se tourne vers le
nunavut
c'est difficile en fait on peut pas
faire abstraction il ya une il ya une
commune une un organisme on avait un
doute qui disons centrale quand on parle
de théâtre c'est un organisme à but non
lucratif qui a été fondée à peu près de
10 en 2008 et qui basé à ical witt
s'appelle quartier à voûtes et puis eux
leur monde leur mandat c'est vraiment de
promouvoir les arts de la scène de créer
des partenariats que les artistes j'ai
artistes policièrement comédiens parce
qu'on est dans le corps une fois dans
différents types de performances
artistiques qui est dans le fond ils ont
produit plusieurs spectacles dont un
dont je vais emmener dans quelques
minutes
donc leur objectif c'est vraiment
devenir un levier de développement des
arts de la scène cuit pour remédier
aussi à plusieurs lacunes parce que je
sais pas peut-être le savait lui le
savez vous déjà mais le nous n'avons
parmi les territoires et les provinces
du pays le nunavut est le seul à ne pas
disposer d'un théâtre à proprement
parler d'un centre culturel où
peuvent-ils en appareils de jouets vélos
en fait quand on a parlé du 20e
anniversaire du nunavut
je pense que c'est dans les projets
futurs exactement donc ça c'est déjà une
problématique assez central par les gens
qui parce que pour pouvoir monter une
pièce il faut pouvoir après la jouer et
puis donc on en lit pas encore l'heure
on est encore dans le plus dans les
balbutiements mais c'est un projet qui a
germé puis qui va éventuellement prendre
forme parce que justement le carrier à
votr lancer une étude de faisabilité en
fait ils ont commandé une étude de
faisabilité pour évaluer toute la
viabilité de construire une école en
fait un pas dans un théâtre où un centre
culturel où pourrait se jouer ou
pourrait pourrait être jouée l'épisode
avoir lieu le spectacle on sait pas
encore s'il se demande si con si le ca
serait plus pertinent de construire un
seul bâtiment ike alouettes ont
construit plusieurs plus petit dans
plusieurs communautés
ceci toujours en cours de discussion
mais l'objectif ce serait aussi de
pouvoir offrir des formations
professionnelles à travers ce bâtiment
là
donc des preuves pour que les gens qui
peut aussi y étudier ressortent de la
avec un diplôme qui seraient reconnues
ailleurs au canada
donc tout ça dans l'objectif de rendre
accessible le théâtre est différent type
de performances artistiques directement
oui dans la terreur là ok on va parler
d'ailleurs d'exemple président a un
petit peu plus tard mais notre éviter
d'arriver bonjour naka bertrand son
métier crise dans le trafic mais très
occupé aussi parce que le festival du
jamais lu commençait le 2 mai donc hier
alors je pense que là vous devez hyper
débordé je vous présente vous êtes co
directrice donc avec marcelle dubois la
directrice du festival du jamais lu à
montréal conte directrice vous êtes 4
cette année en fait codirecteur
artistique
oui donc il ya pascal bleu même et alex
of time and aussi qui qui qui ont
participé à la programmation
oui le fixe n'a qu'un vous êtes une des
nez des territoires du nord-ouest mais
vous vivez au québec depuis déjà très
longtemps donc vous connaissez très bien
la culture ici et je pense que c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on vous a invité à
participer au festival du jamais lu en
tant que co directrice
je crois que oui j'ai fait des études
incluant théâtre avec avec un dock
justement et samarie québécoise aussi
donc je la culture québécoise de très
important et la culture autochtone oui
j'en profite pour vous présenter
isabelle il avait des tas québec
isabelle picard qui est une ethnologue
wendat
alors isabelle n'a kanak à bertrand n'a
qu'à qualité le mandat qu'on vous a
demandé en fait quand marcel dubois et
son équipe vous approchez qu'est ce
qu'on vous demandait en tant
qu'autochtones en fait il n'y avait pas
tellement demande c'était plutôt un
offre s'est comporté comme un beau
cadeau il y avait beaucoup de liberté
mais on avait une idée d'une ligne
éditoriale oui cette ligne éditoriale
c'était vraiment de franchir les
solitudes de passer par dessus les les
solitudes qu'on se crée
et des solitudes générationnel ou
culturelles ou toute solitude le fidesz
et de franchir à travers le théâtre pour
aller à la rencontre de l'autre
isabelle est ce que vous leur compte est
là constaté cette solitude entre autres
entre les autochtones et les non
autochtones par exemple ah oui oui c'est
certain
de moins en moins peut-être heureusement
je vois quand même une certaine
évolution des choses depuis notamment et
dans nos morts depuis que la lumière a
été fait sur les pensionnats tous on
dirait que les la distance entre les
deux peuples les moins importantes
puisque on comprend davantage le
pourquoi de de tout ce qui se passe dans
les communautés les réalités autochtones
qu'on est capable de comprendre les
choses déjà on a un bon bout de chemin
de fait je pense oui oui donc ça a été
une bonne idée de la part de marcel de
vous inclure naka pour justement faire
en fait ouvrir la porte pour que ces
solitudes lan n'existe plus qu'un au
contraire qu'il y ait un dialogue une
conversation et surtout une écoute et
avec de la dramaturgie c'est ça c'est
l'écouté exact est également alors c'est
vous qui avez choisi les divers
autochtone qui font partie de la
programmation du festival du jamais lu
en fait je les ai pas choisis mais ces
mouvements mais j'ai produit de gérer
j'ai proposé qu'on approche certaines
personnes pour faire partie de ce forum
oui et puis aussi on a eu quelques
soumission parce que c'est un concours
aussi pas d'accord on a eu quelques
soumission au festival qui était
quittait autochtone donc on a choisi la
pièce de écrite par des djeun s la
cendre des oh oui
donc on a trouvé ça vraiment bon et hong
kong way fait des génisses qui est un
mâle et site
oui et l'idée derrière sa pièce c'est
c'est de retourner vers les origines
1 oui c'est par rapport à ça oui par
rapport à l'épi génétique et aussi la
mythologie autochtones hockey est ce
qu'il va en fait ce qui arrive c'est que
c'est la pièce elle est écrite déjà mais
elle n'a jamais c'est ça l'idée du
jamais lu c'est que c'est la première
fois qu'on la lit en public c'est bien
ça exactement c'est du jamais lu c'est
très frais et inédites et souvent donc
ce sont ce sont des essais c'est une
première mise en lecture publique
d'accord est-ce que c'est lui qui va la
mettre en lecture ou est ce qu'il ya des
comédiens qui sont engagés pour lire son
texte je crois que ça dépend vraiment de
chaque chaque écrivain de chaque auteur
par loyers des auteurs qui ont vraiment
envie d'entendre quelqu'un d'autre
mettre leurs lectures envie oui puis il
y en a d'autres aussi qui veulent
veulent à lire même d'accord dans aimé
dans le cas d'edf ce sera qui savez vous
je crois que c'est charles beigbeider
attentes
je me rappelle plus exactement ça mais
c'est un comédien autochtone je crois
que va faire la mise en lecture
oui c'est lent voilà donc il ya donc ce
texte là de jenny c'est là vous dis lui
l'a présentée par cette soumission là
oui il ya envoyé un texte au concours
djamel oui ça a été choisi alors il ya
une autre dramaturge eux qui va être
lassé française comme qu'est ce que je
prononce bien son nom je crois qu'on dit
francis cros can oui mais oui elle est
autochtone une femme autochtone elle
écrit une pièce qui s'appelle zag in win
qui est qui qui se traduit en amour ah
d'accord
elle est anglophone donc elle l'a écrit
en anglais
oui et puis c'est une traduction en a
plusieurs traductions cette année on en
a trois oui donc elle a été traduite par
gabriel attendez je vais vous le dire
rires job de l'aisne et gabriel
châtelaine parce que enfin évidemment
tout ce qui est présenté est en français
oui mais par contre on essaie de
franchir les solitudes dans
donc oui il va y avoir un peu d'anglais
un peu de mots autochtone assez bien
d'accord est ce que ce serait possible
de voir une mise en lecture qui ne
serait qu'en par exemple quand ni nou
camp attikameks ou quand malécites à ce
que c'est envisageable
ça se fera pas cette année
nécessairement ça c'est pas cette année
normale mais mais c'est ça cette
réappropriation de la langue est un
enjeu très important pour les
autochtones surtout en cette année qui
est l'ami de l'international
oui oui oui donc à travers la
colonisation et l'inspiration eu
beaucoup de pertes du langage mais mais
c'est un processus qui se fait depuis
plusieurs années j'ai surtout de la part
des jeunes autochtones qui réapprennent
les horribles
oui absolument
alors on va retourner au nunavut pendant
quelques instants parce que on part on
va rester dans la dramaturgie à une
pièce qui a déjà été présenté en 2007
déjà au nunavut
même s'il n'ya pas encore de de balizac
en face était plutôt c'est 2017 ses plus
récentes
il s'agit bien greeters d'ailleurs on
peut peut-être projeté quelques petites
d'image donc encore produite par cars
qui ajoute cet organisme dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure
et puis c'est un grand conseil était une
adaptation contemporaine d'un meeting
donc on est parti d'une légende et de
leur en fait il ya des éléments pour
plus contemporains qui ont été apportées
à la pièce mais l'on retrouve on a
retrouvé les chants de gorge d
et de la danse des performances de
tombeaux aussi donc cette pièce là était
la première production théâtrale
professionnelle en langue hinault et a
effectué une tournée non seulement dans
le nord mais dans les soucis de ce pays
et d'ailleurs ils ont joué sur les
planches de théâtre à toronto en janvier
dernier donc un peu comme comme un
amical le 17 août alors on trouve encore
des éléments qui sont que des éléments
de la culture traditionnel inuit qui
sont occupé une place importante encore
dans dans l'or mais avec une désir de
moderniser d'apporter une touche plus
contemporaines dont mini est ce qu'on
peut parler du futurisme je vais vous
poser la question est ce qu'on peut se
rendre juste je n'ai pas vu j'avais pas
vu parce qu'il est claire elle a été
jouée jeu ça te rend tout dans les
derniers mois mais ils ont également eu
leur destin serait de pouvoir continuer
à la halle à jouer mais est ce qu'on
peut parler de futurisme d'une certaine
manière oui comme je le dis parce qu'on
est dans l'affranchissement du regard
historique donc mais il ya une
convergence entre des aspects plus
traditionnels dont qui sont inspirés des
récits des aînés oui et au et d'éléments
aussi à la fois contemporain mais sa
forme vraiment un tout c'est pas un d
donc on parle pas de repas pas une pièce
qui est in qui est qu'il traditionnelle
ou d'une pièce qui est contemporaine
on est vraiment dans le dans l'
équilibre des deux et ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce qu'on me disait la
directrice artistique justement de
quartier ajoute la coulou que williamson
batterie qui a été que contribuer à
l'écriture de la pièce we me disait
souvent dans le sud on va considérer que
cette vision plus de
cette idée reçue selon laquelle bon il
ya des inuit traditionnels et des inuit
contemporaine mais elle me disait donc
quand à part en faisant référence à la
nouvelle génération qui a peu connu le
nomadisme l'émotionnel gedera puis mais
c'est que l'histoire et la mythologie
est encore tellement central dans la
culture que finalement si si on peut
faire ce portrait l'au delà des choses
évidemment vous en doutez et donc on est
vraiment dans la réappropriation de
pratiques traditionnelles de pratiques
culturelles qui ont jadis était opprimé
drouet
on est vraiment si je pense que même en
théâtre et en tout cas dans le cas de
cette pièce là on est encore dans cette
démarche à laquelle vous vous le
connaissez le théâtre inuit
non je connais pas tellement le théâtre
il me connaît mais qui fait hésiter elle
et les métis données et inuit et puis je
sais qu'elle fait un très bon théâtre
qu'elle ait fait une pièce qui est jo
ici à montréal
oui est ce que par exemple elle aurait
pu être invité au festival du jamais lu
évidemment avec une nouvelle création
puisque faut que ce soit du jamais
jamais parce que ça aurait été possible
oui on a pensé à buca beaucoup de gens
on a pensé à renata aussi par contre
elle ne pas pas français donc c'est un
enjeu et son oeuvre n'étaient pas
traduites sens en oeuvre a été traduite
oui mais on rit jaune
mais oui elle a déjà été lui a déjà été
montée oui c'est ça déjà été vu sur 7
mai une prochaine oeuvre nouvelle
prochaine oeuvre pourrait être présenté
aux jamais lu oui c'est pas fumer alors
autres événements qui vont se dérouler
on va retourner on va retourner à vous
dans quelques instants ce qu'on valait
au nunavik au nord du québec
mais avant on va reparler du jamais lu
parce que outre des génisses et frances
cancun ya également d'autres dramaturge
et d'autres conteurs qui sont invités au
jamais lu oui donc
il ya marie marchand qui est la
directrice
parce qu on a plusieurs en un forum on a
des traductions et oui on a les mises en
lecture et on aussi quelque chose qui
s'appelle les murs à abattre
donc c'est un concept un peu pour des
phares les mets donc alors déjà on à
briser les solitudes et en plus on fait
tomber les murs oui c'est ça c'est bien
donc c'est gratuit c'est de ces temps ci
ça c'est ok puis on a invité louis
calciques linky wendat les fans et c'est
bien oui et aussi je suis ainsi mis pour
pour faire tomber des murs ils vont les
faire tomber comment exactement s'est
des mises en lecture aussi nous comment
ça se passe on les a laissé la liberté
artistique donc ça se fait qu'ils
fassent tomber des murs pour de vrai
qu'ils fassent tomber des murs
littéraire c'est une surprise en fait on
sait pas ce qu'ils vont faire
il avoue piqué ma curiosité records moi
je veux savoir la wii
oui bon l'idée c'est d'aller les voir
évidemment vous allez vous dire oui
allez voir est ces gens faire tomber les
murs tuer isabelle c'est votre voisin
avez vous eu quelques détails sur sa
prestation
non ça maintenant je n'ai pas croisé les
rieurs
mais comme je connais louis carles
d'après moi ça devrait être assez
éclatée assez intéressant c'est un
artiste qui qui a pas pas justement de
défoncer les murs et leur bain
finalement c'est une porte ça permet les
rencontres ça permet les réflexions ça
permet les discussions et lui carl est
un artiste qui est très engagée et ça
devrait vraiment très intéressant comme
prestation alors j'ai vu ça s'appelle
parce qu'il le faut ça c'est le nom son
oeuvre de ce qu'il va présenter parce
qu'il le faut alors oui ça parce qu'il
le faut on peut imaginer à peu près tout
ce qu'on veut à travers ça
et puis vous vous dont vous parliez de
louis carles picard il ya aussi
chassaing si oui est ce qu'il est ou nda
tout si jocelyn oui je pense que oui la
famille si oui est une grande famille
wendat n'est ce pas et lui présente un
spectacle où enfin quelque chose qui
s'appelle traces oui est ce que vous en
savez un peu plus sur traces il est
aussi discret que ça si c'est ça c'est
se comprend bien
oui mais c'est ça c'était de cesser le
concept de faire tomber les murs de
prendre des je pense d des idées qu'on
aime très conçu ce qu'est ce que
quelques caisses que les murs qui nous
entoure et puis de d'essayer d'aller les
éviter ou d'aller les changer ou les
plateaux alors trace sera présenté le 6
mai et le week end picard c'est le 5 mai
donc quatre artistes autochtones
présenté au festival du jamais lu est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres surprises qui nous
attendent
donc on a un forum aussi et puis on a
des des artistes et des académies qui
est des directeurs autochtone dont lorie
marchand et midi monnaie et
véronique hébert qui est une dramaturge
autochtone qui fait son doctorat en
théâtre donc ils vont venir présenter
ben en fait faire une présentation et on
va avoir une discussion un peu après sur
justement les le futur du théâtre
autochtone ce qui se passe de ses jouets
futur du théâtre autochtone c'est ce
qu'on parlait là de fumel futurisme il
ya le futurisme autochtone et ya le
futur du théâtre d'automne
mais je pense que l'un et l'autre sont
aussi vivants et ont un avenir tous les
deux
oui je suis d'accord totalement d'accord
parce que le théâtre c'est ouais ça
parle
c'est un c'est un médium artistique et
libre qui laisse passer
ce qu'on vit donc c'est très vivant et
puis alors parlant de théâtre là on va
aller au nunavik parce que là aussi il
ya des des projets qui se déroulent du
côté du nunavik alors deux projets au
pluriel si je dirai pas qui on a
énormément fait jaser moi j'ai pris
l'exemple de la en fait ce qui est
l'exemple le plus connu ou l'équivalent
de carrière votre disons au nunavut
c'est la compagnie théâtre inuit du
nunavik qui est une troupe de théâtre
qui n'est toutefois pas basés au nunavik
ils sont
en fait à montréal c'est en fait ils
sont dirigés par l'institut culturel
avataq oui comment s comment fonctionne
en fait vu qu'ils sont pas basés au
nunavik généralement il offre des
séminaires des ateliers à des étudiants
directement dans les écoles aux normes
et par par portion de par séjour d'une
semaine ou deux semaines donc c'est rare
cirque
non c'est pas alors alors fixés ils sont
plutôt spécialisés ont été en cirque et
puis sont ils sont basés de loulé comme
la vôtre
oui donc lorsque l'autre ça fait la
compagnie théâtre inuit du nunavik le
sens et ça c'est une compagnie une
troupe de théâtre qui a été qui a été
créée en 2008
en fait à l'heure lors leur mandat
premier c'était en fait à la suite d'une
étude sur l'état de lino petit tout à
l'issue de cette enquête là une des
recommandations du rapport
ça va c'était de créer et de développer
le théâtre en hymne aux petits doutes on
lève ou nunavik d'accord depuis leur
première production ils l'ont fait en
2011 4 par dont la prononciation wicca à
ut qu'agit ageuqat j'ai pas de photo à
aller y prononce en fait pas très bonnes
mais désolé pour l'accrochage mais dans
le fond il y aurait fallu console pour
me les voilà qui on est quelqu'un de la
production mais dans le fond ça a été
aussi un peu comme sur l'exemple quand
je venais tout à l'heure c'est
inspiré d'une légende inuit qui relate
elisson dans leur ferait mal traités et
en fait ce qui s'est passé
malheureusement à cause des défis des
coûts des coûts financiers
la pièce est décliné sous forme de
ballade ou de radio de balados qui a été
diffusée dans des les radios
communautaires donc on a donc c'est un
enjeu qui est important étant donné
qu'ils sont pas basés au nunavik
les coûts de déplacement des fois pour
une production derrière les coudes les
coûts de déplacement avant morcelé une
grande partie du budget de la production
je dirais par contre l'enjeu dans cette
troupe 6 et c'est pas forcément le fait
qu'ils ont pas de théâtre ou de centre
ou au pouvoir ou ceux où se jouer
contrairement à nunavut parce que à
coups de joie qui a le kativik que
tiendra ou parce qu'il ya un nouveau
centre où est ce qu'ils peuvent pour
jouer sinon à accoudoirs appliquer le
centre multi fonctionnel captiva vie
qu'ils étaient construits récemment 2010
est donc un nouveau centre culturel
aussi où est ce qu'ils peuvent
oui mais ça c'est plutôt sur disons les
défis sont plutôt dans le fait de pau
est basé au nord ça serait utilement
leur objectif être composé aussi
majoritairement d'inuits leurs objectifs
sont multiples en fait athènes c'est
vraiment disons qu'ils sont encore aux
balbutiements mais
éventuellement il devrait pouvoir créer
des partenaires des partenariats avec la
commission scolaire kativik pour donner
des ateliers à des étudiants créer un
festival directement au nunavik son
autre projet ils ont des projets je
pense que l'ambition est vraiment là
c'est juste que c'est toujours les
problèmes la question financière qui est
un peu derrière toutes les mêmes
difficultés du côté du des territoires
du nord-ouest 1 il ya la distance aussi
qui peut rendre certains projets plus
difficile oui la distance géographique
et qu'il ya quelque chose de très
importantes au canada
oui oui et donc oui parfois ramener les
gens ensemble c'est un face à face c'est
petit plus c'est malheureusement avec
les têtes des technologies ont pu un peu
partagé nous oui absolument nulle
manière et les murs brisés l'exercice
l'arrondi encore ah ça oui
autre projet pour terminer mais en fait
c'est le seul exemple c'était l'exemple
que j'avais à vous montrer les deux
pièces au nunavut que nous n'avez que si
je pense que c'est des exemples on
retrouve un peu les éléments de
futurisme théâtrale
de futurisme inuit ils sont partis dans
les jambes et illusion à porter
différents éléments plus contemporaines
encore une fois oui dans la
réappropriation de
de l'art de leurs cultures ou est ce
dont on parlait en début d'émission avec
isabelle à l'autochtone au futurisme
c'est voler remet le terme consacré
maintenant voilà alors on revient au
festival du jamais lu pour terminer
l'événement est en cours actuellement
ça a commencé hier est ce qu'il ya un
engouement est ce que ce que vous avez
entendu là depuis les dernières heures
il ya un engouement pour ce qui va se
faire également avec ses oeuvres
autochtone en fait ben oui enfin c'est
parti on s'est lancé yves de talhouët
parce que pour marcelle dubois c'était
donc une priorité cette année de donner
la voix aussi à des dramaturges
autochtone oui justement parce que il ya
eu toute tendue avec canada et slaves et
puis c'est vraiment important de parler
de qui le droit de raconter ses
histoires et pourquoi on les raconte
aussi donc
donc je crois que c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est vraiment une
programmation très intéressante cette
année je suis vraiment très fier d'avoir
participé et je suis vraiment très
contente que marcel et eu d'ouverture
d'esprit de mes invités à faire partie
de ce programme en sursis merci beaucoup
naka d'être venus nous rejoindre
malgré les conditions difficiles de la
route au studio l'acca bertrand merci
beaucoup
isabelle à owen d'accueil puisque vous
êtes là quelques pas du wardak et merci
beaucoup
on vous revoit la semaine prochaine et
on wheels oui exactement mais vous serez
en studio ici à montréal alors ah oui là
la semaine prochaine isabelle guérard
mois et puis merci à matisse harvey qui
sera aussi avec nous la semaine
prochaine un sujet que nous vous ferons
découvrir au cours de la semaine
merci d'avoir été là encore une fois au
revoir